today's video is sponsored by magellan
tv an amazing documentary streaming
service founded by filmmakers for the
love of history their mission is to tell
the great stories that have defined the
human experience and with more than 3
000 excellent programs available on
magellan it's hard to stop watching once
you start they've got everything from
the greeks to the great war plus modern
history biography scientific profiles
true crime and so much more and their
team adds more content every week there
was one thing you love about paid
streaming services there are no ads just
as and as of true to life bingeable
content now if you're looking for some
wholesome holiday content tis their
season after all their magellan can get
you started with titles like the legend
of santa and in search of santa claus or
you can stick to more traditional
historical docu-series the ancient
history genre particularly good over
there this holiday season you guys can
take advantage of a special holiday deal
with magellan by clicking the link in
the description below snag a buy one get
one free deal for an annual membership
that way you can give the gift of
magellan and still keep a lid or
something for yourself it's content for
days and days so let magellan hook you
and a friend up you'll be glad you did
and now today's video
you were too fast to live too young to
die this is how the eagles remember
today's protagonist in their 1974 song
in his lifetime he only starred in three
films and only one of them was released
while he was still alive and yet he
became one of the most influential
actors and pop culture figures of the
1950s and beyond on the silver screen he
set the template for the quintessential
rebellious youth in his private life he
craved speed he sought passion from both
girls and boys and he obsessively
courted death but he also yearned for
the love and affection of a regular
family took any occasion to learn
everything on anything to improve
himself and to leave his mark on the
acting world this is the story of james
dean and how a hollywood icon was made
[Music]
james byron dean was born on february 8
1931 in marion indiana 17 months after
the wedding of 19 year old mildred marie
wilson and 22 year old wynton a dean
winton had been a farmer in indiana but
after taking a job as a dental
technician he relocated the family to
santa monica california when jimmy was
only eight mildred died of cervical
cancer winton did not know how to cope
with being a single father wynton's
mother emma offered some advice jimmy
could go and live with wynton's sister
or tents who ran a quaker farm in
fairmount indiana with her husband
marcus wynton dean agreed it turned out
to be the right choice as he was drafted
into the army 18 months later and he
wasn't cut out to be a single father
plus autenson markers turned out to be
excellent parental figures for jimmy but
as a result james and wynton dean never
developed a close relationship and the
future actor would constantly seek
surrogate parental figures jimmy had an
idyllic childhood in fairmont his uncle
and aunt became mum and dad and he grew
attached to his cousin joan as the big
sister he'd never had when joan got
married during the war and rice was hard
to come by jimmy toured all over the
stalls in the county and until there was
enough to throw for the newlyweds
authentic marcus on their part did their
best to encourage jimmy's artistic
inclinations as his mother mildred had
done before if you were a lazy casting
director for an 80s comedy you'd take a
look at the kid and cast him as the
stereotypical school nerd he was short
awkward and he wore thick horn-rimmed
glasses and dental braces and yet jimmy
excelled in everything
except academic subjects he played
violin brass horn and drums he tap
danced and painted he excelled in both
the high school basketball and baseball
teams but his greatest passions were
acting and motorcycling according to his
grandma emma the realization he should
pursue acting came after his appearance
in a church play in which jimmy played a
blind boy well i'll tell you i wish he
wasn't quite so good at it i cried all
the way through besides family members
jimmy's greatest influence in his
teenage years was his pastor reverend
james dewey a decorated world war ii
veteran and friend of winston churchill
the clergyman encouraged the young dean
to pursue his passion for the stage and
for the race course dawid also
introduced jimmy to philosophy classical
music and the notion that he should seek
his true self beyond the physical and
ethical confines of small time america
the older james taught the younger james
that conformity is cowardice a concept
ironically jimmy put into place by
conforming to his mentor's worldview
like a psychic vampire jimmy absorbed
every possible teaching from dawid to
the point of adopting his convictions
and mannerisms this was to become a
recurring pattern in dean's life jimmy
would cling on to a surrogate parent or
other mentor figure he would then drain
them of all the culture and knowledge
they could offer and then he'd move on
to the next provider of mental energy
when the two talked about bull fighting
and car racing the reverend introduced
the ever-present possibility of sudden
death in such occupations but sudden
death should not be feared if one
believed in personal immortality sudden
death followed by immortality the future
star's fate had been sealed
1949 jimmy graduated from high school
and moved back in with his dad winton in
santa monica california he enrolled in
the local college where winton insisted
that he studied law but of course he
dedicated way more time to the
performing arts one of his drama
teachers mrs jean nielsen oh and took
him under her wing while his raw talent
was undeniable his poor articulation
made him barely understandable fellow
students blamed this on the indiana
accent but nielsen realized the problem
was caused by the dental braces
eventually she helped fix the
annunciation problem by having dean read
hamlet for a whole term dean then
transferred to the university of
california los angeles and majored in
theater in his first months at ucla
james dean did not make an impression he
was withdrawn awkward and did not mingle
easily with the theatrical clique even
his acting chops did not stand out
against the average of the students at
that stage he felt more at home with the
jocks and the frat boys as he had joined
a greek fraternity his attitude changed
when he joined the informal classes held
by actor james whitmore who had studied
in new york and imported the more
sophisticated east coast techniques to
hollywood it was during his classes that
he had an epiphany this was the style
for him a new direct and realistic
acting style heavily influenced by the
system of russian director constantine
stanislawski this was an approach which
required actors to plunge deep into
themselves to retrieve those memories
and emotions which could match their
character's psychological state it was
at whitmore's classes that jimmy finally
clicked with the clique of more
promising acting students in particular
he got acquainted with william bast who
had become one of his best friends and
lovers as jimmy fell in with the acting
crowd he got estranged from his
fraternity friends one night one of the
frat boys made a snide remark against
the thespian community and jimmy reacted
badly
very badly the argument degenerated into
a huge fistfight dean had to leave the
frat house and he moved him with bast
the two were so strapped for cash that
they lived by candlelight subsisting on
oatmeal mixed with mayonnaise bast also
learned to cope with jimmy's frequent
and unpredictable periods of depression
during these spells he felt completely
silent and it was best to avoid him
completely those downers were followed
by periods of intense electric energy
during which vampire jimmy was able to
learn new skills in a matter of days
clinging to one of his psychic supplies
and in between those extremes dean
appeared to most as an intense awkward
young man goofy and endearing one moment
arrogant and dismissive the next during
one of his restless periods dean landed
his first paying acting jobs after some
tv commercials he was cast as john the
baptist in an easter tv special called
hill number one the reviews were quite
good so good in fact that jimmy got an
agent and some minor roles followed
mainly in radio and tv dramas but he
also scored non-speaking roles in sailor
beware with dean martin and jerry lewis
and has anybody seen my girl with rock
hudson jimmy was elated to find that he
had to speak one line in the war drama
fixed bayonets but the scene was edited
out during this brief stint james got a
brief glimpse of hollywood's glitzy
lifestyle he had started dating young
star beverly wills daughter of noted
comedian joan davis through beverly
james took to hanging out with a crowd
of promising actors and artists around
sunset strip the meow initially excited
dean as he was exposed to a whirlwind of
contemporary art literature and music
that he'd never heard of as usually
clung to meant to figures like a
barnacle and became an instant expert in
any new topic of interest but he could
not find a viable human host jimmy
turned to books based on accounts from
his close friends it appears that he had
some issues with reading although never
explicitly stated he may have suffered
from dyslexia that is why he preferred
to absorb knowledge via conversations
rather than the printed page but he
developed an uncanny ability he could
skim over a handful of pages of a book
to absorb the most complex concepts he
was then able to hold entire
conversations about those topics fooling
people into believing that he was a
total expert on for example platonic
philosophy
[Music]
eventually jimmy and beverly broke off
their relationship and he grew tired at
the sunset strip mob in fact he was sick
of hollywood and los angeles as a whole
late in 1951 with a few possessions in
his case james dean issued conformity
and bravely moved to new york looking
for an edgier scene and a more intense
life on the east coast dean resumed his
routine of small bit parts on radio and
tv he even appeared on cheesy quiz shows
where his function was merely to have
pies thrown in his face his new
girlfriend was aspiring dancer elizabeth
sheridan known as dizzy the daughter of
pianist frank sheridan the two moved
into cramped lodgings and were soon
joined by william bast the trio took to
hanging out with a circle of young radio
tv and broadway professionals and jimmy
became friendly with producer rogers
brackett bracket later said that their
relationship was actually of a sexual
nature to the benefit of both rogers in
fact was happy to introduce dean to the
who's who of the new york theatrical
scene and it was thanks to him that
jimmy lem eyes in the summer of 1952 a
producer working on the staging of see
the jaguar a new play by n richard nash
dean had cast his eyes on the role of a
teenager locked for years in a smoke
house operated by an overprotective
mother but production did not progress
so he turned his attention to further
honing his craft it was during this
period that james entered the legendary
actors studio this is where acting coach
lee strasberg inspired by stanislavski's
teachings had honed the method simply
known as well the method this is the
school that would forge the talents of
marlon brando montgomery cliff geraldine
page meyer and monroe and later robert
de niro and al pacino at the age of 21
jimmy was the youngest member of the
studio his chops greatly impressed
fellow students visiting directors like
elia kaizen and the man himself mr
strasberg although apparently the two
never got on well strasbourg made dean
the target of his frequent barbed
critiques pushing him to spill his
metaphorical guts into his roles dean
was not eager to let strasbourg dissect
me like a rabbit in laboratory
eventually jimmy took to describing
strasbourg's acting instructions as
mostly hot air and hog
in august dean joined the ires family on
a 10 boat cruise not as a passenger but
as a crew member on their yacht he had
adopted lemire's and wife as his new
york surrogate parents and took the
occasion to drain them of all their
nautical knowledge along the way he
carved a good lasting impression on the
producer the boating trip was followed
by a break-in fairmont during which
jimmy introduced bast and dizzy to his
aunt or tents and his uncle marcus this
was probably the only occasion in which
william bast observed james dean to be
completely at ease with himself and
those surrounding him bast and dizzy
also got to meet winton jimmy's dad who
joined them at the farm for some days
dizzy observed how father and son were
shy and respectful to each other as if
wary of breaking a fragile emotional
balance she found their relationship
endearing but in reality they had grown
too distant too different to have a
proper rapport winton did not hide the
fact that he could not understand and
accept jimmy's lifestyle nor his choice
of becoming an actor mr dean would have
hoped for a more solid profession for
james little did he know that it was
about to pick up the holiday at the
quaker farm was in fact cut short by a
call from new york buyers had decided to
cast james and see the jaguar after a
successful run in provincial theaters
the play landed on broadway in december
1952. the abrasive new york critics
metaphorically ripped the script to
shreds spat on it and then wiped their
shoes the place sucked apparently and
they closed it after five nights the
only redeeming factor was the
performance of young unknown actor james
dean new job proposals kept pouring in
the most interesting one being another
theater production the immortalist based
on the novel by andre guide here james
played the role of bashir an algerian
young man who seduces the male
protagonist the rehearsals apparently
were no walk in the park as jimmy
related to bast director daniel mann was
openly hostile against him as jimmy saw
directors as surrogate fathers hostility
on their part was especially
demoralizing but jimmy may have done his
part to drive the rest of the cast and
crew totally nuts during the rehearsals
he met befriended and seduced another
aspiring actor john gilmore in his
memoirs gilmore recorded how dean was
uncommunicative with the cast or how he
read his lines flatly and slowly
mumbling through dialogue or improvising
without warning most of the cars could
not stand him and almost had him fired
the only colleague who stood up for him
was geraldine page it was no coincidence
that paige was aware of dean's
difficulties with reading in dean's own
explanation to gilmore before he could
properly act a script he needed plenty
of time to read it digest it and
memorize it he had to swallow the script
take it into his stomach and fart it out
let me say this apparently on opening
night 8th february 1954 james farted the
right way because he impressed a
hollywood heavyweight director elia
kasen according to sources it was either
thanks to geraldine page or jimmy's
agent jane dc that kazan realized that
james dean should be the lead for his
next film east of eden based on the
novel by john steinbeck the plot
revolves around cal trask a young man
with a fractured relationship with his
strict father who sees him as a good for
nothing and a troublemaker in fact cal
fit james like a glove kazan noticed it
even if he did not like james on a
personal level he knew that he had cast
a star in the making jimmy returned to
hollywood to start filming and it was
during this time that he met rising star
pierre angeli born anna maria pierre
angeli in sardinia the italian actress
had caught the eyes of hollywood casting
directors and just recently moved to
tinseltown apparently their relationship
never went beyond a strong friendship
and a total spiritual and cultural
affinity it was clear that the two were
meant for each other and even loved each
other deeply unfortunately pierre's
mother stepped in she was still very
young and her mother managed all aspects
of her career including who she should
be dating her mum objected that dean was
not catholic and was worried that his
reputation as something of an oddball
could compromise pierre's rise to
success eventually the italian actress
married entertainer vic timon according
to bast they say when pierre married
victimone jimmy stood across from the
church and cried in the meantime filming
for east of eden had wrapped and warner
brothers had offered a new role to james
dean his most iconic one the character
of conflicted teenager jim stark in
rebel without a cause by nicholas ray
the movie was one of the first big
productions to deal with the disaffected
youth of the post-world war ii
generation it introduced tropes such as
knife fights amongst teen gangs or
lethal chicky runs with powerful racing
cars at a deeper level it is an
exploration of the troubled psyche of a
young man and woman disappointed by
parents and authorities who were either
distant overbearing or just plain
inadequate jimmy the actor and jim the
character she had a passion for speed
dean had spent his first hollywood
paychecks on a brand new motorbike and
while he whizzed around la producers
insurers and friends were dead worried
that it'd break his neck a friend of
kazan's thought that jimmy's idol marlon
brando might talk some sense into him
jimmy had always pined for brando's
attention a feeling that the older actor
had always shrugged off when the two met
brando warn dean to get off the bike as
an actor with half a face is no actor at
all
and that seemed to do the trick jimmy
sold the bike and bought a porsche
satisfying his need for speed with
sports cars he took to road racing
winning two trophies in his first
competitions but according to bast he
was not pursuing accolades rather the
excitement of taunting death more
precisely he may have been pursuing that
elusive sudden death leading to personal
immortality that sublime and macabre
concept that he learned from reverend
weird
[Music]
dean had little time to speed around the
racetrack though after rebel had wrapped
he was immediately cast as jet rink and
george stevens as sprawling texan epic
giant albeit important the role was not
a lead one but it did not matter to dean
as he got to star alongside hollywood
royalty like rock hudson and elizabeth
taylor director stevens had a hard time
working with dean who frequently erupted
in fits of rage or long sulky spells but
the veteran filmmaker decided to make
the most of it asking the
cinematographer to keep cameras rolling
in between takes to capture those unique
moments co-star liz taylor also bled to
cope with dean's mood swings and the two
became good pals but the closest
friendship was the one that dean forged
with set photographer sandy roth and his
wife balua the trio had a common
interest in photography and eventually
the actor came to adopt the couple as
his newest surrogate parents yes the
same pattern repeating itself again dean
spent much time at their home engaging
in endless discussions about films and
art raiding their fridge and playing
with lewis the couple's siamese cat liz
taylor took notice and decided to give a
present to james a siamese kitten for
the first time dean had to look after
another being which he decided to name
after his uncle marcus the kitten had a
positive influence on dean's life it
gave him a sense of responsibility and
normalized his habits as bass noted
jimmy even took to returning home
earlier at night and yet a few weeks
later he confessed to the wraths that he
had given the kitten away he was
concerned that his professional
commitment would not allow to properly
look after marcus in fact james had just
been cast as the lead and somebody up
there likes me the real-life story of
boxer rocky graziano and besides that he
realized that he led such a strange and
unpredictable life that some night he
might not return home again he wondered
then what would happen to marcus maybe
this was a eerie premonition of his
sudden death it wasn't the only one
around that time on the 22nd of
september 1955 james dean had a chance
encounter with alec guinness in l.a the
british actor took a look at his new
porsche 550 spider and said you'll be
dead if you get into that car some days
later on the 30th dean and his mechanic
rolf wutherich were driving the porsche
to a race in salinas california at 3 30
pm they were given a speeding ticket
later while driving along route 466
dean's porsche got into an accident with
another car driven by student donald
turnipseed the 550 spider was devastated
from the impact turdup seed and
rutherick were severely injured but
survived james dean driving at the
moment of impact was killed almost
immediately he was 24. james dean's life
had burned bright blazed fast and
disintegrated far too soon but his fate
would be spared oblivion only one of his
movies was released during his lifetime
east of eden rebel without a cause
premiered in 1955 and giant in 1956.
both films were popular and critical
success as an audience has simply could
not ignore dean's peculiar intense
heartbreaking yet realistic acting style
a legend was born ironically after his
death at the 1956 and 1957 oscars james
dean was nominated for his performances
in east of eden and giant respectively
he didn't win the awards ultimately but
to this day dean is the only actor to
receive two posthumous oscar nominations
besides the self-destructive tendencies
besides his philosophizing about sudden
death followed by immortality james dean
was serious about his craft and
development as a professional actor had
he lived he would have been set to
achieve legendary status perhaps his
career would have followed a trajectory
similar to that of paul newman the actor
who inherited his role in the rocky
graziano biopic or more likely he would
have trailed the progress of his idol
marlon brando another method illuminous
manly yet vulnerable who became both a
darling of the academy and a hollywood
maverick but besides all the what-ifs
the three movies left by james dean
influenced entire generations of actors
and filmmakers and left an enduring
legacy on american popular culture
perhaps larry carte of the chicago
tribune summarized it best on the 30th
anniversary of dean's death when all is
said what james dean managed to do
was enough
so i really hope you found this video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching
[Music]
you